Here are the real politic.
We love talking about Asia and do you
probably know that by now and we like it
because there were certain things that
this region has the can contribute a
loss to the improvements of all.
Yeah.
Wow.
How was it?
Not Everything is as good as it sounds
it Asia.
While we can certainly see plenty of
lights,
there are also lots of shadows and the
largest shadow is that without any doubt
the area has become a huge powder keg
ready to blow.
On the one hand,
the area is spending more and more in
weapons.
In fact,
it is expected that by 2020 the region
will accounts for more than 30% of all
of the welds military spending.
On top of that,
it's also becoming a chess board for geo
politics.
China and India are big emerging powers
and with time they are demanding a
larger and larger international
influence.
Putin's Russia has started to feel
concerned by the Pacific hands.
Well,
so as the United States,
this area is extremely important.
Now on the other hands,
there are many disagreements between the
different countries in this region and
it seems that lately they have been
looking for any reason to start a fight.
We can find all kinds of conflicts here
back in.
I'll make territorial historical,
I mean China,
China's conflict with Vietnam here with
Japan over there,
and then there is India.
The situation with Taiwan and the
problems between Japan and Russia,
that's not even considering the
situation in Korea.
I mean the list just grows longer and
longer.
We own stalk about many of these,
but today we're going to focus on the
sleeping giants and that's Japan.
Okay.
Two nightmares of Japan.
It is the world's third largest economy,
but despite that,
this country has a modest role in
international politics and it's been
that way for the last few decades.
However,
the situation is changing particularly
for two reasons.
China and North Korea.
First,
there is the emergence of China as a
superpower,
but why does Japan care about that?
Well,
basically because the emergence of China
has led to sets Max in Japan's regional
influence.
Both countries maintain a bit of
conflict.
Over a small archipelago known as the
Senkaku islands.
Senkaku islands are abandoned,
but they're still a key area in the
fishing industry,
be called large deposits,
petrol and gas,
and there are also strategic in sea
trade.
Just take a look at this chart to see
how the military budget of both
countries has evolved in the last few
years.
He'll give you a better understanding of
Japan is concerned about China's
emergent.
Second Zahn more recently there is North
Korea.
How's it been obsessed for the last 20
years about developing unconventional
walk capacities.
These are mainly being its nuclear
capability for now.
North Korea has managed to create it.
Atomic bomb 30 Keela tons,
which is comparable,
do twice the bomb that was on her Russia
map.
They've also succeeded in making
ballistic missiles which can reach not
only South Korea.
There's also Japan.
March,
2017 North Korea launched for ballistic
missiles and Japan's direction it was
successful and three out of four of them
reached Japanese territorial waters,
less than 200 miles from the Japanese
code
Si.
All of this is producing a real
psychosis in Japan.
The Japanese government itself has
started to conduct evacuation drills in
the event of a hypothetical attack and
does either distributed a detailed guide
to explain how Japanese citizens should
respond to to a North Korean nuclear
attack.
Tokyo says that people should have about
10 minutes to react to that might be an
overestimation.
Yeah,
Ms.
May
not be detected as soon as it leaves
launchpad pending on the case.
The warnings and alarms might only sound
four or five minutes before a missile
arrives.
With all of this going on,
we shouldn't be surprised to find out
that Japan is acquiring many nuclear
shelters as well as equipment for
purifying the air,
which all designed to fight radiation as
well as poisonous gas
lobby the Japanese prime minister has
confirmed.
North Korea also has the ability to
launch serin gas missiles,
so ignoring whether the North Korean
threat is real on us.
The reality is that China and North
Korea are perceived as being significant
threats by Tokyo before explaining how
the country is planning to fight these
threats.
Let's have a look at what has been the
foundation of their defense policy in
the last few decades.
Pat a passivist country,
Japan was one of the countries that lost
World War II.
As a consequence of this defeats the
country had to establish a constitution
in 1940 700 that constitution is still
enforced today in this constitution.
It states that war and the use of force
is not to be used unless in self
defense.
Firing sincerely to an international
piece based on justice and order.
The Japanese people forever renounced
war as a sovereign right of the nation
in order to accomplish the aim of the
preceding paragraph,
land,
sea,
and air forces as well as other war
potential will never be maintained.
Article Nine of the Japanese
Constitution.
This means that at first the idea was
that Japan couldn't even have an army.
The country protection was the
responsibility of the u s however,
the Korean War and the tensions suffered
during the years of the Cold War changed
everything.
All of a sudden,
both Tokyo as well as Washington
understood it was essential to form a
support force for the American army.
In case Japan and needed defense and
that is how the Japanese self defense
forces were born.
This is an army whose only possible
purpose is defense,
but one thing is tree.
Formerly the U s still takes cat of
Japan's protection and keeps more than
40,000
soldiers deployed in the country and
also maintains some of its largest
military bases in Japan.
This is a forced,
by the way,
that is co financed by the government of
Japan itself.
We could even say the Japan is the
largest spearhead of the U S in Asia.
However,
the new threats Japan perceives in the
region from China runs North Korea,
of course,
Japan's and no longer be satisfied with
this protection.
So the big question is how is Japan
responding to these threats?
Are these new diplomacy?
It's the beginning with the Japanese
Prime Minister Shinzo all they has
started an unusual diplomatic race who
work against the growing influence of
China.
For now,
he has managed to improve the country's
relations with South Korea and to
strengthen its bonds with the u s and
even bridge the gap existing with
Putin's Russia.
Japan maintains an intense dispute over
the sovereignty of a small archipelago
known as the Kuril islands,
which Russia claims is now under their
sovereignty.
In fact,
the diplomacy are,
they has started is so intense that the
country is now competing with China in
Africa,
Japan and China Compete for African
market.
I'm just a curious fact.
Shinzo all bay was also the first
international leader to meet with trump
and the famous residents the American
President owns in Florida.
It seems like after this encounter all
bay manage,
do you win over the president's and
Macon?
Forget all the attacks made against
Japan when he was still a candidate for
the presidency because one thing is true
from complained quite a lot about Japan,
but you know,
things can change.
Made it to the security of Japan and all
areas under its administrative control.
The friendship between our two peoples
runs a very,
very deep,
of course diplomacy is not always enough
and we are.
And so finally we reached the key
points.
The Japanese Self Defense Forces often
thought of as some sort of small bands
of men,
but really nothing is further from the
truth.
The Japanese army is larger than the
army of France and the UK combined.
No,
it is true that given their name,
you may not think that they are
important,
but the abilities and capacity of this
stream,
Jami is impressive.
Many analysts,
they are still the best army in all of
Asia,
although China certainly competes for
that top spot antidote.
Japan's investment in defense is quite
low with less than 1% of its GDP,
but that is still a lot of money.
Take a look at this.
In 2016 Japan was the country with the
seventh highest spending on defense.
In 2017 the governments will give,
the force is the largest budget in its
history,
more than 5 trillion yen,
which is around $45 billion and of
course such a quantity in such a small,
and by the way,
very well trained army is enough for
them to acquire some of the most modern
systems available.
For example,
there's the f 35 the best American
drones,
the Zulu Pass aircraft,
or even the new fifth generation fighter
jets,
which Mitsibushi is developing.
Japan reveals the prototype of it's
splashed furtive fighters.
The thing is that since all they became
prime minister in 2012 he has had to
declare idea of leaving behind the
pacifist character sent by the Japanese
Constitution Ams.
This has happened in 2014 the Chinese
government decided to stop all
restrictions on the export of warfare
material with the goal of starting a new
Japanese military industry a bit later
in 2015 are they all say ladder reform.
So for the self defense forces could
operate abroad and today they even have
a military base in Djibouti brands.
Of course the military budget has
increased again,
often many years of budget cuts,
but not only this,
they aren't even thinking about changing
the constitution.
The radical military shift of Japan
echoes the ghost of World War Two so now
it comes to the point in the video where
we ask what you think.
Do you think Japan should leave?
It's pacifism aside,
should Japan given to Beijing?
Which country?
He seems like a better ally for you.
Japan or China?
Well,
please leave your answers in the
comments below and do click like if you
enjoy this video.
Also,
don't forget to checkout our friends and
reconsider media.com
the podcast where you can hear the voice
of this video that isn't mine,
and don't forget to subscribe to brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next.